how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we have some really great news
about not one not two but multiple
projects coming to the mcu both in the
theaters and on disney plus we have
confirmation of a shang chi sequel
confirmation of a shang chi spin-off
which we'll talk about in depth in this
video and we have ant-man and the wasp
quantum mania news one of the villains
because there are going to be multiple
villains in this film we have details
about one of the villains for ant-man
and the wasp quantomania so in this
video we'll talk about these upcoming
projects and break down everything that
we know about them so far and of course
if you love marvel be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest mcu news and videos so shang-chi
and the legend of the 10 rings was a
massive success for marvel it's one of
my top five mcu favorites now and it did
incredibly well overall so it should
come as little to no surprise that
shanghai is going to be getting a sequel
i actually talked about this a while ago
because i had the chance to interview
the director for xiangxi destin daniel
critten and the last thing we talked
about in the interview the last thing
that he told me was that there are a lot
of plans already happening and that they
were thinking about the sequel when they
shot the first one uh it seems like it
alluded to a sequel do you have anything
mapped out for the sequel yet that you'd
like to do
yeah i mean even while you're shooting
the first movie in in
the marvel world that's kind of the fun
part is you kind of know your your movie
never ends um so there's lots of
brainstorms happening and
and what ifs being thrown around already
so there's a lot of exciting things
planned for the future already so
today's report from deadline comes as
little to no surprise as they say in
their headline destin daniel crenton
inks overall deal with marvel studios
and hulu's onyx collective set for
disney plus mcu series and xiang chi's
sequel now what does this mean well
according to deadline they say that
destin daniel crenton has entered into
an exclusive multi-year overall deal
with disney companies marvel studios and
hulu's onyx collective and they actually
state that destin is already in
development with marvel studios on a new
mcu series for disney plus now deadline
goes on to say that there is no word
about what this disney plus series could
be however we pretty much know and if
you've seen chongqi as well you pretty
much know thanks to that post credit
scene but all the way back in october
daniel rpk actually reported that shang
chi and the legend of the ten rings
would be getting a spin-off series on
disney plus and he stated that it will
focus on the tin rings organization and
again if you saw the post credits for
chiang chi you know why this is the case
and spoiler alert in case you haven't
seen it at the end zyling took over the
tin rings organization her father died
and she took it over now shang chi
believed that she was going to be
dismantling the ten rings but of course
as we saw at the end she just redid it
she brought it back to life but she
added females because her father never
let women train so now it's actually a
bigger tin rings organization with men
and women and it seems like xylene has a
lot of plans and she has razor fist and
john john right by her side so the
disney plus series has been announced
and it looks like we have figured out
what exactly it's going to be it's going
to be a disney plus show focused on
xiling and the tin rings organization
now we're not sure when this is going to
come out but i'm not sure they're going
to go into too much details about the
actual tin rings artifacts the weapons
the other post-credits scene for shanxi
made it seem like the rings were very
very ancient and could possibly be alien
they sent out a homing beacon at the end
to who knows but it looks like that's
what shangchi is going to be dealing
with in the future and possibly some
avengers as well that seems pretty big
scale so i'm not sure they're gonna dive
into that in the tin rings organization
series but i'm sure shanxi will pop up
in the series after all it is about his
sister and i'm assuming that's going to
come out before the sequel to shanghi
where this will all kind of tie together
where the rings come from what xialing
is doing with the tin rings organization
it's all going to come full circle when
we finally get that sequel hopefully
we'll learn more about telo in the
sequel because that's something that i
really want to know about in the movie
they said they had cities in tallow that
were far greater than any cities in the
world that shang chi lives in that the
main mcu lives in so i'm certainly
hoping that we get a little bit more of
a deeper look into that now for some
really awesome ant-man and the wasp
quantum mania news according to an
exclusive report from thedirect.com
ant-man 3 is bringing modok to the mcu
in a big way and i gotta say right now
ant-man 3 is shaping up to be a super
big movie i personally really enjoyed
ant-man 1 and ant-man and the wasp and
sure they weren't super huge movies but
i still really enjoyed them but this
movie ant-man 3 is about to be a huge
movie we're going to have kang the
conqueror and modoc in one movie and not
to mention darren cross is rumored to be
making his return as well which is
exciting because yellowjacket has always
been ant-man's arch enemy but here's
what the direct has to say about modok
and they do mention that aim should be
coming along with modoc as well they say
modok was reportedly included in a
previous script draft for quantum mania
that was written by paul rudd himself so
it seems that the villain managed to
survive rewrites long enough to make it
to the final film and i do remember
reading about that i do remember that
paul rudd did write an entire ant-man
script by himself and he actually had a
lot of crazy cool stuff in the script
and modoc was one of them and it looks
like they liked that marvel studios
liked it the direct goes on to say given
that aim was also a part of this past
version and the group's association with
the villain it's likely that the
organization will also make an
appearance alongside modok too now
here's the big question what role will
modoc have in ant-man and the wasp
quantum mania because jonathan major's
king is supposed to be the big bad
villain not just of ant-man and the wasp
quantomania but of the mcu so where does
this other big villain take place what's
his role well there's speculation right
now about two possible answers to this
and if you didn't know modok is actually
an acronym and it stands for mechanized
organism designed only for killing he
works for aim but due to an experiment
gone wrong he ends up taking over aim
and he gets a over developed freakishly
huge head but has insane genius level
intellect and psionic powers so here's
the two roles that modok could have in
ant-man 3. one is that he could actually
be a rival to king kang is a genius and
if we're dealing with nathaniel richards
he actually comes from the future a very
very advanced future and given what we
learned from loki no doubt kang
definitely has some plans however i'm
assuming modoc probably has some plans
as well and as the direct points out
there is a chance that the plans could
kind of interlap with each other and one
of them might get in the way of
another's so we could see modoc and kang
clashing heads however as the direct
points out an alternative could be that
modok may actually help kang he could be
an asset to king the king we met in loki
was well aware of his variants in fact
i'm pretty sure all kings would be aware
of their variants since they all went to
war with one another and history tends
to repeat itself so we can assume it'll
happen again and if that's the case the
king that will meet an ant-man and the
wasps quantomania might want to get rid
of the others and modoc is a mechanized
organism designed only for killing if
you're trying to kill somebody he
probably would do a good job especially
if you wanted somebody smart on your
side so kang and modok could actually be
working together in ant-man quantum
mania and let's also not forget that
bill murray is going to be joining
ant-man 3 as well this has been
confirmed maybe he's playing an aim
member who knows but this movie is
looking to be truly epic and not to
mention cassie lang should be becoming
stature and this could be the start of
the young avengers now unfortunately
we'll have to wait until mid 2023 to
find out but luckily there is a lot
happening in the mcu before then but let
me know how excited you are about a
shanghi sequel about a 10 rings
organization disney plus show focused on
xylene and of course about ant-man and
the wasp quantum mania let me know down
below don't forget to like the video and
for live updates you can always follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
[Music]
you